okay. As many of you know, I am not a socialist.
I am a social Democrat. That probably doesn't
come as a shock to people who have been watching
this show or listening to the show for a while.
Social Democrats are capitalism lists
in the sense that we are not trying to overthrow
capitalism and replace it with socialism or
Marxism or communism or some system in which,
uh, there's no more private property, private
businesses, et cetera. We recognize the many,
many, many failings of capitalism, but we
want to fix them. And one of the reasons that
capitalism has to be fixed is that it doesn't
work for tons of people, but the interesting
thing about this is that if you want some
form of capitalism to remain, you had better
damn well fix it because the longer and longer
it goes without working for millions and millions
and millions of people, it makes the system
more at risk of being overthrown by some other
system. This was the concept in fact of Marxism
that eventually there would be this uprising
of the proletariat that would take down the
bourgeoisie. Of course it has not happened
in the United States, but the worst capitalism
is the more likely that that becomes.
That gets us to today's sort of news, which
is that case in point, there's a new poll
which says seven out of 10 millennials would
vote for a socialist candidate. I do wonder
whether the people responding to the poll
actually know what socialism is because it
seems like lots of people talk about socialism
and they don't actually know what it is, but
let's assume for a second just for the sake
of discussion because the analysis is still
an interesting one. This poll was released
yesterday. It finds 70% of millennials are
either somewhat or extremely likely to vote
for a socialist political candidate. 50% of
millennials have a somewhat or very unfavorable
view of capitalism which is up from last year.
Overall capitalism is still viewed more favorably
than other economic systems, 61% positive,
but this is a very clear trend line even if
many of these people are mixing up socialism
and social democracy.
The trend line is clear and this is why social
Democrats who are for better regulated social
capitalism need to fix capitalism and by the
way, not that I'm in the vulture capitalist
free market, laissez Faire type of camp. If
you're a VAR, vulture capitalist and you want
to keep some form of capitalism, this should
be a wake up call for you as well. This is
why you need to be fixing capitalism with
the socially democratic reforms that people
on the left of the democratic party have been
talking about for many years. The least damaging
thing to a capitalist is to fix capitalism
or they risk some other system actually, uh,
becoming something people really and truly
want. You know, when Donald Trump says during
his state of the union, we will never be a
Capitol, a socialist country. Uh, he doesn't
know that. As I've said before, things change
in countries.
They can change slowly, they can change more
quickly than sometimes we believe is possible.
Uh, but the reality is that there's no real
risk right now of the U S becoming actually
socialist. You know, college tuition paid
through taxes is not socialism. A Medicare
for all isn't socialism, gun controls, not
socialism, but the right has both successfully
and unsuccessfully used the term socialism
as an argument to attack these socially democratic
policies. But eventually there's going to
have to be some accounting because as capitalism,
as we know, it continues to fail more and
more people and fail to provide a basic standard
of living and allow these just sickening excesses
of wealth to accumulate more and more and
more at the top. Millennials who see that
system is failing them. Why wouldn't they
be open to some other system? They don't see
all of the great things that capitalism is
bringing them because it's arguably not brought
them a lot of great things.
So of course they're going to look at something
else because our version of capitalism is
fundamentally broken. So if you really want
to tout the benefits of capitalism, and by
this I mean some of the main tenants, right?
Private property, private business ownership,
uh, taxation, which tends to be progressive
taxation. Although, you know, different people
argue about how progressive it should be.
Lots of the things that we have. If you want
to really make the case that it's working,
you've got to make it work for more people.
And that includes making sure no one drops
below a certain standard of living. That includes
cutting down on the corrosive influence of
money in politics and an influence peddling.
The data is increasingly clear on this. Something
will have to be done or other systems, even
misunderstood systems, and this is why I said
you know, a lot of people don't know the different,
don't realize what socialism actually is.
It doesn't matter because no matter what your
assessment is of what capitalism is and what
socialism is, if people understand that the
system as it exists is not working for them,
it becomes harder and harder to argue that
this is the system that we should keep